[Music]
what who's this guy standing in like he
all badass hey we need a lift
where you going I'm going over just
going across the street to the intrepid
yeah I know it's a killer no no you
never know when you might need a power
tool of course it will do us no good
with your automobile just in case didn't
NASA invent those No well we did have we
did have a power a pistol grip tool a
PGT that we don't abbreviate stuff this
is denied in NASA headquarters thank you
leave the abbreviations behind a pistol
grip tool that pistol whip tool grip
grip tools there's a web tool that's
what I heard Chrissa whip bullwhip tool
we had a power better to call it a power
tool I've got a power tool that they
invented to be used on Hubbell yeah then
it was used to put together the space
station as well oh really
yes and then we invented a smaller
version more like this that was kind of
big we invented a smaller one like this
for the last Hubble mission because he
had a lot of little screws to use it
okay so we got it you know how to light
on it and it was a high speed low torque
kind of stuff so yes we invented tools
but I don't know if we would did you
know that this boy repaired my Hubble
telescope did you know I didn't know
that you know if I didn't he would have
left me there exactly it's my telescope
I'll pick you up everyone
that thinking is that thing you didn't
bust that thing or else the repair well
we did a bunch of things but when we
used to do we used a power tool to take
big instruments in and out of the
telescope okay cuz they were lockdown
with latches that have these these bolts
on them that we that we use the power
tool with the lunch room and just boom
back in right what you click here the
telescope you you serviced it we
serviced it correctly yeah it's May
right exactly so service it means you
upgraded we did actually do repair in
the last mission we did fix a couple
instruments that we needed to get inside
of it had bad power supplies doing a
nice job Jim you this is not easy to do
this is is this harder than astrophysics
no hard to be an astronaut I say yes
astrophysics is a different story
go to the intrepid museum well you know
because Neil was telling me about the
space shuttle that yeah actually at the
intrepid have you ever seen it I
actually have not well I thought I've
seen the space shuttle but not the Space
Shuttle did you see the one on TV to see
a launch and here I'm sure you've got to
see launches I saw two launches sir you
would probably invited to everyone I
sought to launch did you see ours
no all right would you remember towards
yourself yeah unfortunately I saw 107
yeah
that was the last time we launched
Columbia so was that the last come on
107 was Columbia yeah okay yeah and once
the mine in tree right right you got to
see a good launch yeah it was it was a
clean launch yeah
and that one had yeah why why'd you go
sit down because at the time I was a
board member of the Planetary Society
founded co-founded by Carl Sagan and the
Planetary Society sponsored an
experiment that was a jointly jointly
conducted by an Israeli and a
Palestinian student nice okay
look at that the space program bringing
people on earth together Chuck made a
good point here though you know he said
I think one is I think one of the
benefits of the space program which or
of science in general that's
underestimated is the ability for people
to cooperate even though they may not
have anything in common right you said
no I didn't do photo Paul you don't text
them so don't follow my queen so now is
the guilt to see his guilt okay so we
got only Israeli thing what do you got
so all right just with the Olympics are
you know so that's interesting let me
look this up yes and so I ranked in the
tweet yeah the four highest investments
civilization has made in cooperation
Wow so the number one the world wars
together two seconds that's a little
cheating though oh it's it's quiet
largest investment in International
Cooperation right that is what this list
is all right world war world war
interest to the United Nations okay
three International Space Station all
right for the Olympics really the
Olympics is the oldest World War II the
United Nations both came out of War
World War it's sort of the ISS is like
the left here that's the only one that's
actually played or cooperation and if
itís not even the Olympic it's a kind of
a representation of war yeah and still
they got the javelin that spirit that's
throwing spears yeah right shot put just
yeah in the end wrestling boxing that's
okay even track and field is just people
running from the bottom
violence beamed and the marathon was to
do telling other people that they won
the war the city of Marathon how do you
know all this one city block all right
unusually long but look how much we've
learnt city block
so some believe was it Athens in
marathon the two cities in Greece all
right yeah and and a battle occurred and
this dude ran dude ran and I'm told it
was 25 miles came up with it but that's
not the length of the marathon 26.2 or
so how do you get 26.2 is a kilometer
transfer no it's not it what is it it's
not a a translation error no it's
because the first marathon run in the
Olympics started in front of Windsor
Castle or one of them one of the sights
of the of the royalty all right and you
have to end the marathon we're in
England one place you end the marathon
in the stadium in the stadium you turn
into the stadium you do that one victory
lap okay 26.2 miles away freakin bring
the Brits messed it up could have been
nice around 25 mile lane and on em man
and you know what it's the point to
Mouse crap another lap sucks I was fine
- I was fine that that is why I've never
run a marathon because I can go 26 Neil
you know I would have to find the
restroom the entrance had a toilet right
by that point too that's why i don't run
there